the pressure is hilariously building on
lying Republican Congressman George
Santos or Anthony De volder or whatever
his name is to resign yesterday there
was an event held by the Nassau County
Republicans and a bunch of other
officials and it is just delightful and
I am increasingly hopeful that they are
going to force this guy out and you know
that they love to say oh they're trying
to destroy his career
he lied about everything he deserves to
have his career destroyed sometimes it's
right for you to lose your job folks
here is Nassau County Republican Jared
Joseph Cairo saying that George Santos
should resign immediately the reason
this is the district he represents
that's why we're talking about Nassau
County the County Republican committee
nor should he serve in public service
nor is an elected official he's not
welcome here at Republican headquarters
for meetings or at any of our events as
I said he's disgraced the House of
Representatives and we do not consider
him one of our Congress people
today on behalf of the Nassau County
Republican committee I am calling for
his immediate resignation now this is
all great and I love it and we'll get
George Santos's reaction momentarily
increasingly it seems as though Nassau
County Republicans knew that this guy
was lying about a bunch of this stuff
it's not been definitively proven but
it's increasingly looking that way so
really what they're they're having a
problem with is that this makes them
look bad I don't know that they actually
care about George Santos lying about
everything it's that now everyone knows
George Santos lied about everything and
it makes them look really bad it's still
very funny here is
um a claim that George Santos claimed he
was a volleyball star at Baroque College
which he didn't actually graduate from
and that he had a champ a volleyball
championship look at this
explain what was on that resume well to
my recollection it said he went to
Baruch College said he went to NYU he
later or perhaps at the interview I
didn't attended uh that he sought a
master's degree said that he worked in
finance I don't recall was it city city
group I think uh said he was very
successful told me personally that that
he had made a lot of money at that age
and was successful in life
we got into it started getting personal
about the fact that he came from a poor
background but that he was able to be
very successful told me I remember
specifically I'm into sports a little
bit that he was a star on the Baroque
volleyball team and that they won the
league championship
what can I tell you it is a joke but
also the joke is these Republicans who
it seemed like they had these suspicions
for a long time and now all of a sudden
they're like well the guy should resign
I actually remember when um George
Santos uh developed an incredible
surgical technique back in the 1930s and
it was a real real big advancement in
medicine as you can imagine next we
heard from Republican Congressman Brian
Fitzpatrick now this is Meaningful
because this is Fitzpatrick who is a
sitting member of Congress saying he
shouldn't be here and you know Kevin
McCarthy has resisted saying this type
of thing
um Fitzpatrick says he simply should not
be here to happen before the house
leadership
you're you know part of that
joins the calls for Santos to resign
yeah thanks for having me Andrea I don't
think he should be here that's for sure
but there's a process in place that has
to apply equally to all members from
both parties in both Chambers and that's
a house Ethics Committee as your panel
just pointed out to the extent that
there's concerns about how long that
would take we should just have an
expedited review there's got to be a
system in place that's consistently
applied across the board all right so
anyway kind of playing a both sides sort
of thing but he is saying George Santos
shouldn't be here then we heard from
Hempstead Town supervisor Donald Clavin
who says that the guy is a joke and he's
making them a joke and it is true they
were already a joke though that's the
thing he's just George Santos is making
them more of a joke you see a unified
voice here now what he's unified the
country and their opposition to him he's
a national joke he's an international
joke true but this joke's got to go
right and is on us calling him for to
resign immediately not tomorrow not next
week today all right so George Santos
confronted at the House of
Representatives Yesterday by Rachel
Scott but will you resign he says that
he will not take a look at this yes
the New York Republicans are calling you
a disgrace you will not resign
all right so off goes Congressman Santos
de valder whatever his name is I really
hope they push this guy out this
everything else aside Republican
complicity in this they knew when did
they know all this different that
Republicans are dishonest I hope this
guy gets pushed out and I hope it
happens soon let's talk about a couple
other George Santos lies you may
remember that a few years ago uh the
show got hacked and many thousands of
dollars were stolen we never got it back
it's a terrible feeling it can happen to
anyone but a couple of years ago we got
Aura which really gives us significantly
more peace of mind and our sponsor Aura
is the app that protects you from
scammers by alerting you anytime your
info like email passwords social
security number are found in data
breaches or also automatically requests
removal of your info from search engines
and it can reduce spam calls Aura alerts
you quickly about suspicious credit
inquiries like if someone tries to take
a loan out in your name and or as
password manager makes it easy to keep
your account secure to begin with aura
also has parental controls for your kids
devices you can restrict apps or manage
screen time set Focus time make sure
they're doing homework instead of
binging on YouTube you can try Aura free
for 14 days at aura.com Pacman use the
free trial to see if your email password
are already out there you may be
surprised the link is down below